well joining me now is former
conservative Minister Ann whitakam and
historian Dr tester Dunlop also with his
Royal editor for the Sunday Times were
knicker and former BBC role editor Jenny
Bond so a veritable Galaxy of luminaries
to debate this let me start with you
Roya again because you had a big story
on Sunday in which your sources at the
palace were basically indicating that
notwithstanding the onslaught that's
come their way King Charles in
particular was prepared to consider
reconciliation before the coronation in
may now I've got to say before I get you
to talk about that my own sources
tonight who I would describe as pretty
impeccable
um believe that's a bit of a reach say
that Charles is absolutely livid and
actually reconciliation right now is
most definitely not on the cars there's
been no contact whatsoever with anyone
in Montecito and that may well stay the
same so let's let's thrash out our
sources here how confident are you that
you think that Charles really does want
to reconcile with somebody who's really
shown that any attempt to do anything
just immediately gets commercialized
well good evening peers I think sources
aside if you speak to people who really
know the king they will tell you that he
absolutely does not want to be estranged
from his son for the rest of his life
there is no doubt that Charles has lived
the whole royal family probably live it
about what Harry has done but we have a
few months now very very crucial months
leading up to the coronation and
actually one of the most extraordinary
lines in that book was Harry's
Revelation that Charles said to him and
William after Phillip's funeral please
boys don't make the rest of my life a
misery which at the moment
um Harry is doing a very good job of but
what Charles will not want really great
one is a strange one from his son
forever and any kind of major
overshadowing of the coronation and if
there is nothing done no contact at all
between now and the coronation I really
do think we're going to keep hearing
from Harry and Megan in a very negative
way and and Charles will want to avoid
that but you know what my response would
be it's like all right keep yapping if
you want to you've done your worst on
honestly keep yapping and just
completely ignore them don't invite them
to any Royal events I mean Jenny Bond
why the hell should they be invited to a
coronation it's the people's coronation
it's our coronation for our Monarch all
they've done these two is damage the
monarchy damage the reputation of that
institution damage their family the
royal family on which the monarchy's
future depends what on Earth have they
done to deserve an invitation to a
coronation well no it's not just Charles
by the way it's Camilla as well getting
crowned who Harry just trashed in his
book
yeah well I think you know this is the
most important day probably in the whole
of Charles's life and if as the loving
father which I believe him to be he
wants his younger son to be there then I
think that is his right and his
privilege and I think an invitation will
be extended to them I I think to not
invite them really is going to be uh
feeding the hind the bites Charles so
it'd be wise to invite them and uh if
they do come uh I think we the media
actually should take it upon ourselves
not to make it not to make it overshadow
the coronation I mean we don't want to
have screaming headlines about them so I
think we should just have a footnote at
the bottom of our coverage of the
coronation and say also in attendance
were the Duke and Duchess of Sussex I
think that might be one approach
you'll be bringing Tessa Dunlop
um look you are the great apologist for
the Megan and Harry here's my question
for you why would two people who hates
everything the Royals seem to stand for
hate the monarchy are intent on
destroying it have done nothing but
trash it and diminish it in the last two
years why on Earth would they want to be
at a coronation of the next monarch of
this country pears I thought you'd read
the full 400 pages of spare and you will
have got the message loud and clear
there is no macro Harry plan he is a
died in the wool royalist no he doesn't
yes I'm afraid he's going about it all
the wrong way he's done unspeakable
damage but he wants to save the money no
no no I'm being serious
Tessa let me just respond to that what
he wants is to keep the titles the Royal
titles for him and his wife because it's
the titles that make the money and
they're making hundreds of millions of
dollars his book number one Global
bestseller his documentary series huge
success blah blah blah of course it is
he's trashing the royal family from the
inside it is a boy in pain
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry who grew up in
a goldfish is he in pain or has he ever
been happy which one is it he's telling
us how happy he is who grew up in a
goldfish Bowl who's thrashing his way
out of the Gilded cage but actually as
well as he doesn't know how to exist
without the Gilded oh no he does I
incidentally I'm no apologist for Harry
but I do apologize on your behalf
because one minute you set their peers
and you say oh they'll keep yapping away
they should be ignored there is no way
if they so much has thought that you
would ignore what they say you stoke the
boiler oh let me be clear let me be
clear people say this to me and go why
do you keep banging on about me why do
you because they keep trashing the
Royals in podcasts in books in
documentary Series in interviews it
never stops and I say to them now I will
stop writing and commenting about them
if they just shut up go to Camp
Montecito so be the happy people you
keep telling us that you are stop
trashing the royal family stop attacking
our monarchy stop diminishing this
country if you do that I'll leave you
alone
the dignified Jenny Bond reduce it to a
footnote please but you couldn't resist
doing that because like them you make
money
I bow to nobody of course I do everybody
who's involved in covering the rules my
case makes fun well you're making money
appearing on this show tonight double
time yeah exactly so you're making money
too out of it so let's not be Hypocrites
Jenny Bond look no I'm bouncing nobody
in my admiration of Jenny Bond but she
would have been the first in her
previous capacities the BBC's Royal doin
to probably not actually reduce them to
a footnote the coronation because you
know it's a big hot story and this is
the problem and with him isn't it is
that is it unfortunately everywhere they
go so does the lens of attention because
they make it their job to make sure that
we don't leave them alone that is
exactly why I think they should not be
at the coronation for this reason I
asked myself a very straightforward
question which will be the bigger circus
if they don't come or if they do come
and if they come they're likely to be
booed we all know that there'll be a lot
of attention on them because they're
there well that'll be the story they get
booed at the coronation exactly whereas
if they're in Montecito totally agree
we're all free to concentrate on the
coronation so I feel very strongly they
shouldn't come I also hang on you had a
long go I also feel equally strongly
that the Royals should not be proposing
a negotiation meeting because we've
heard Harry's terms he wants an abject
surrender I wouldn't trust him as far as
I could throw him that's the point I
mean
um this is the problem I would have if I
were Charles and William in particular
um is how do you trust them how do you
trust them given that almost all their
private conversations with Harry have
now appeared in this book including
really intimate stuff including a prince
Phillips Funeral and so on how on Earth
can they trust him to have some sort of
private meeting which stays private
well that's a great question and that's
something that's even been acknowledged
by sources close to Harry and Megan he
said to me and I've written that that
even they acknowledge that there's an
issue there that perhaps the royal
family might not trust that private
stays private but what I would say is as
much as it might stick in the core of
many many members the royal family
particularly the ones you've just
mentioned who come on to heavy fire in
the book I think if the king isn't seen
to somehow do something I think he's
going to come onto even more heavy fire
from his son and other people down the
line but but that will be the great test
I think if they if they do propose some
sort of I'm not saying a negotiation but
some sort of sit down and then something
leaks out and it comes from Harry and
Megan's side then I think it probably is
game over but at least the king may have
tried yeah I mean look Jenny Bond it is
a I feel incredibly sorry for for
Charles he's lost both his parents in
the space of two years he's probably
still mourning his mother who just died
a few months ago he's taken on the
monarchy you know he's our new monarch
he's about to be crowned the king of
this great country three I mean all
these huge pressures both personally and
professionally and then he's got his his
young son causing just total endless
Relentless Mayhem I mean my if that was
one of my sons I've said to them I've
got three boys in my 20s one of you does
this to me and goes Rogue like this
that's it Bang there won't be any
reconciliation parties you're done
well you see I don't think he wants to
lose his son as well as having lost his
parents and I do think that uh Charles
is quite a compassionate guy and I think
he would probably agree with me that
what we're witnessing here is almost the
unraveling of a youngish man who um is
so mentally fragile now and so confused
there's so many errors in the book
um and conflicted within himself and
really suffering and like I agree he's
had some terrible things
I want to pick you up on that thing
about the mental health thing I don't
see somebody suffering or in pain I see
a smug little narcissist making a ton of
cash abusing and revealing secrets about
his family I don't see anyone fragile
whatsoever you know on the one hand he
says I'm the happiest I've ever been on
the other hand he wants us to believe
he's a pain struck young guy he's not
he's nearly 40. you know he's had a long
time to get over of the pain that by the
way millions of people have to go
through losing parents when they're
young it's not not exclusive to him his
own brother went through exactly the
same thing and doesn't seem to feel the
need to trash his family in public so I
just don't really Buy in Jenny to this
you know he's racked with pain and is so
fragile I think he doesn't give a damn
about the damage to the mental health of
all his relatives and yet he's supposed
to be the prince of Mental Health
I think he is right with pain and in his
book I thought it was very very moving
when he said that one for you for a
second lot of therapy
um he was frightened of losing the pain
he had felt for all those years for the
loss of his mother he was frightened of
losing that pain in the therapy because
he would lose his mother again and I
thought it was incredibly moving now I'm
not going to defend Harry for all he's
done or he said a lot of it's abominable
most of it's loopy and I agree I think
he's he's a little bit unbalanced and
deluded perhaps because all the drugs he
took I don't know
his mental health I think he's a I think
he's a California we meet him all the
time when you're out there uh Tessa
Dunlop you've been raging away as normal
you know what have I said this wrong you
are renowned for lacking empathy I won't
use that I've got plenty of members
I actually have a lot of empathy for the
right people actually and my entire
career
empathy no no I so empathy for the
people who deserve it Harry is not
deserving
who has watched Harry from birth through
the death of his mother you don't have a
shred of empathy for his peculiar
lifestyle that's trained him for nothing
that's left him with doubles of
expectations
I went to a state school and actually
what he should have done is go to a
state school and you're also you're
grimacing yeah I'm absolutely just just
calm down the power of you I've got a
perfectly calm neither of you signed it
at the moment now can I just Rich coming
from you you're normally the one blowing
up but go on I've actually sat here
trying to get a word for a long time
but I mean let me make this point the
culination is not just a personal
occasion now you can understand the
father wants to involve his son in all
sorts of things and it's but it's not a
royal wedding it's a coronation it's an
occasion of State
and you've got to ask yourselves what is
the most dignified way that we can have
this because it is an occasion of state
and therefore there must be a great deal
of dignity that won't be by having Harry
Potter I totally agree it would be
literally like having the Kardashians
sitting there uh please stay with me uh
my panel here Roy are we going to say
goodbye to Roy another busy week for you
I know you're writing busily away again
presumably your next big scoop on Sunday
so thank you we're looking forward to
speaking to you about that whenever it
drops I appreciate you joining us thank
you very much